- There is one guy in Russia
that Vladimir Putin, the president,
fears more than anyone else.
(indistinct chatter)
He wears a lot of different hats.
He's a political
activist, he's a YouTuber,
he's kind of an internet troll.
He's a lover of quality drone footage
to help expose corruption,
which like, come on,
who doesn't love a good drone shot?
(upbeat music playing)
But his main objective is singular,
it's very focused,
it's to give the Russian people
and all of us around the world,
a peek behind the curtain
to show how Russia really works.
Exposing the web of
bribes, corruption, lies,
and powerful men who really
control modern Russia.
This important figure who is seeking
to dismantle Russia's web of corruption
is named Alexei Navalny.
And just last week,
he was sentenced to three years in jail
as well as being nominated
for a Nobel Peace Prize
after being secretly
poisoned on an airplane.
(airplane whirling)
The movement that he has created
strikes at the heart of
Vladimir Putin's biggest fears
and I wanna show you why.
So let me introduce you to
the man Putin fears the most.
- [Reporter] Alexei.
- Russian opposition leader.
- [Reporters] Alexei Navalny.
(upbeat music)
Okay, so let's rewind
to summer of last year.
Alexei Navalny is in a
city in Eastern Russia,
he's in a hotel room,
about to head to the
airport to catch a flight.
When he arrived to the airport,
other passengers recognize him
because he's kind of a big deal in Russia
and they snap some photos with him.
Then he gets on the flight,
the flight takes off,
it's a four hour flight from this
city of Tomsk to Moscow where he's going.
Everything's going normal
for the first 30 minutes of this flight,
but then Navalny starts to feel weird.
A flight attendant offers him
a bottle of water and he refuses,
but soon this feeling weird
turns into severe pain.
(airplane whirling)
He runs to the laboratory
looking for some reprieve.
He's going in and out of consciousness,
he may be going into a seizure,
his heart is slowing down,
his muscles are convulsing and seizing,
no one has any idea what's happening.
A nurse aboard steps up and
helps keep him conscious
while the pilots reroute
for an emergency landing
at a nearby city in Russia.
The plane lands at the closest airport
where medics sprint
onto the runway to help
only for the medics to say,
and I quote, this is not a case for us,
he needs intensive care.
Navalny is then rushed to a hospital
but what happens inside this hospital
is kind of mind blowing.
(cameras flashing)
When he gets to the hospital,
they start running tests on him
to see what's going on.
But when the doctors come looking
for the results of these blood tests,
the lab technician hands them a blood test
that says that Alexei
Navalny is totally fine,
nothing out of the ordinary,
maybe a little bit of
irritable bowel issues,
but that's not what the doctor has seen.
This man looks like he has been poisoned
(airplane whirling)
but the lab technician
didn't hand over any results
that indicate that he was poisoned.
Something is up.
The doctors go ahead and
go with their instincts
and treat him for poisoning
because that is the symptoms
that they are seeing.
They put them on a ventilator
and they put him into a medically
induced coma to recover.
Over the next few days,
Alexei Navalny is in
the intensive care unit,
in a coma, in this hospital.
But the hospital starts to fill up,
not just with doctors
but Russian government officials
who start barring people like his wife
and his personal doctor
from entering the room.
Navalny and his family do not
feel safe in this hospital.
It's at this time
that a German humanitarian
non-profit organization
offers to charter a jet
to fly him from this town
in Russia, out of Russia
to be treated in Berlin.
(upbeat music)
Soon, he's on an airplane to Berlin
where he arrives at a hospital
and they run all of the
same poison blood tests
that they did in Russia,
but this time they find
that he was poisoned.
This would have come up
on the test they did in Russia,
but somebody decided
not to reveal that to the doctors.
- Mr. Navalny remains in an induced coma
at a Berlin hospital.
- The German doctors are
seeing that the poison
that was somehow administered
to Alexei Navalny
is some crazy nerve poison
that sends the victim
into a state of paralysis
and gives nerve damage,
and inducing seizures,
and making their heart slow down.
It's a poison that was developed by
Soviet scientists during the Cold War.
(cameras flashing)
And they used it to quietly attack people
they wanted to get rid of,
like spies or double agents.
It's called Novichok, and
it is a brutal poison,
and it was the poison that
was used on Alexei Navalny.
- Tonight this incredible story,
the most prominent
Russian opposition leader
is in a coma on a ventilator.
- Now there's a lot of
ways to poison someone.
You can use ingredients
that anyone has access to.
Novichok is something
that is developed and used
only by the Russian
Military and Intelligence.
In a sense, it's a signature,
so Navalny goes back into
a medically induced coma
in this hospital in Berlin
where doctors are doing
their best to treat him
and also investigate what happened.
Soon, the world would know
exactly what happened.
(recorder screeching)
Okay, let's just pause for a second.
Well, Alexei Navalny
is in a coma in Berlin
because we need to ask
an important question
which is, who is this guy,
and why on earth is Soviet nerve poison
being used against him?
(bright upbeat music)
For most of his adult life,
Alexei Navalny has been
dedicated to one thing,
which is a shining light
on how Russia really
works behind the scenes.
Not this or this, but how it really works.
One thing you need to know about Russia
is that the whole society, the government,
the business structures, everything,
is built on a giant
house of cards let's say.
It's delicate, it's fragile,
but it's the status quo
and Putin is at the top.
From there you have the
people closest to Putin's,
the ones that have his ear,
the rich Russian billionaires
who control Russia's main industries
like oil and gas, mining, telecoms,
all the richest guys in Russia.
These guys do favors for Putin
and Putin does favors for
them in the political sphere.
They scratch each other's back,
and in doing so, they maintain control
over everything that gets done in Russia.
And this model repeats itself
as it trickles down to
regional governments
and then to town and city governments
who all operate in the same manner,
keeping the society stable
through a culture of bribery,
secrecy, and intimidation.
And it all happens in the name
of keeping Putin secure in his position
so that he can in turn
keep his rich friends happy.
The reason why Putin fears Alexei Navalny
is because Navalny wants all Russians
to see exactly how this works,
to shine a light on it
which could easily turn the
people against the system,
to knock down this house of cards
from the ground up,
to stop putting up with a government
that works for the rich corporate owners
and not for the people.
And if this happens, it's Vladimir Putin
who has the longest hardest fall.
Okay, but here's the
juiciest part of the story,
and the part that got me
into this and that I love,
which is that the tactics Navalny uses
to do this shine a light
on the system thing,
there's no better way to
describe it than saying,
he's full on trolling Vladimir
Putin and his friends.
(Alexei speaking Russian)
He does this in a lot of ways,
but what I love the most
are his well-produced
internet explainer documentaries.
(Alexei speaking Russian)
He makes these long videos
exposing the indulgent corruption
of Russian billionaires
who control the country.
And he uses these visual
investigation techniques
that are really stunning to
look at and really convincing.
But there's also a good amount of
snarky, poking fun in
every one of his videos
like this deep dive
into the corruption of
this Russian politician
that starts with this goofy iPhone video
of him awkwardly dancing at
like a wedding or something.
(man speaking Russian)
But it's not just all poking fun,
these videos then go very deep
and they reveal really useful
and compelling evidence
that shows just how bad this situation is,
just how in bed the government is
with these rich billionaires,
but always peppered with
a good amount of this.
(upbeat music)
He's like a viral internet sensation meets
like, hardcore, journalists,
activists, video vlogger guy,
he's just an interesting character,
so what is Navalny?
He's kind of a politician,
but he's more than that.
His specific policy agenda has more,
and it's honestly like not that noble,
like he totally supported
the annexation of Crimea
which is like totally off limits
and a terrible thing that happened.
And his electability as a
leader, isn't very likely
but that's not really at
the heart of his mission.
His mission isn't about being elected,
it's about dismantling the current system,
not to convince people to vote for him,
but simply get people
to vote against Putin
and the status quo.
And here's why this scares the
(beep)
out of Vladimir Putin.
Back to our house of cards,
even though Putin is at
the top of this pyramid,
it doesn't mean he's all powerful.
He's not like a standard
totalitarian dictator
who just has everyone under his thumb.
He's only powerful because
he's in the good graces
of all these super rich guys
that own the massive companies of gas,
telecoms, mining the
natural resources in Russia.
If these guys turn on him, he's over.
Putin, while powerful is simply one cog
in the machine of keeping
these guys powerful
and immune from laws and regulation.
Putin isn't afraid
that all these YouTube
videos are going to create
legal issues for Putin and his friends,
the courts in Russia
are just as influenced
by this culture of
bribery and intimidation
as everything else,
he's not afraid of that.
Instead, he's afraid that
the people might realize
that their government is controlled
by a bunch of billionaires
and start demanding that
Russia be more transparent.
(slow music playing)
Some accountability for these rich dudes
and the leaders that support them.
And like I said, if that happens,
these billionaires might be able
to slip into the shadows
and run away to some other country.
But Putin will be the
public face of the person
who's kept this arrangement together,
he will be enemy number one,
his fall will be the greatest
that is why he's afraid.
In a sense, he's painted
himself into a corner
and he's past the point of no return.
He must maintain the current system
or he will face the wrath of his people.
So far, the only person who has actually
garnered that wrath is Alexei Navalny.
- How corrupt do you think
is Mr. Vladimir Putin?
- He's the basement of this corruption,
he's personally involved in corruption
and he's encouraging our
official for corruption.
It's his wave of ruling country.
- [Man] Vladimir Putin
made his first visit
since Russia annexed Crimea-
- Vladimir Putin cast his shadow
across the boundary of Europe and Russia.
- So Putin goes to greater
and greater lengths
to ensure that he remains
popular among his people
and show the billionaires
that he's still the right guy
to keep this system of corruption going.
He does this in a few ways.
The first way, he keeps
popularity among his
people is my favorite,
and it looks like this.
(upbeat music)
He stages these absurd photo ops
where he's like surveying the land
on a horse with no shirt,
or playing hockey with a bunch of
literal professional
hockey players from Russia,
and he's actually better than all of them,
and he scores eight goals
in the course of this video, it's amazing.
(upbeat music)
And people actually buy this,
they like to see their
leader like super powerful.
And then secondly, he
keeps his people happy
by actually leading the
country in ways people like.
His approval rating remains quite high.
But more and more,
as Putin and his house of
cards feels threatened,
Putin is resorting to more extreme means
to keep this system secure.
(man speaking Russian)
Okay, so we got the backstory
on Russia and Alexei Navalny,
let's get back to Berlin, to the hospital,
to the ICU where Alexei
Navalny is in a coma.
(slow music playing)
He finally comes out of this coma,
and by then, the world has
looked into the details
of him being poisoned on this airplane,
and it becomes clear that this is the work
of Russian government agents
who snuck into his hotel
and laced his underwear
with this lethal nerve poison.
Alexei Navalny is big master
of trolling and pranking,
and he immediately responds to this.
Did he download some basic
call spoofing software
that any of us could download?
And he masks his number
as a number coming from an
intelligence secure line,
and he calls an intelligence agent
who has COVID and is like ditched out
in his house at 7:00 in the morning,
and he's like delirious,
and he goes on to pretend
that he is a leader
and the intelligence agency
has all this insider information,
and he teases out a confession
from this intelligence agent
that indeed they were the ones
behind this poisoning.
(man speaking Russian)
I'm not gonna play a bunch
of that phone call here
but I'm gonna put a
link in the description
and you need to go listen to it
because it is insane to listen to.
So, what's Navalny's next move?
He's in Berlin, he almost got killed,
he's now having to learn to walk again
because the nerve poison
like really f'd him up,
what does he do?
He decides to do exactly
what he's always done.
Instead of cower and stay abroad,
he decides to return to Russia
to face Putin head-on.
Upon his return,
he releases a documentary
that is his most epic documentary yet,
he was working on it
before he got poisoned.
This one focuses entirely on Putin
and his network of bribes, cronyism,
and loads of amazing drone footage
of Putin's lavish palace on the Black Sea.
In true Navalny fashion,
he makes it clear that he's
going to release the film
after he returns to Moscow,
because in his words,
(Alexei speaking Russian)
(upbeat music)
The documentary becomes
one of the most instantly
viral videos ever to appear
on the YouTube platform.
It currently has 110 million views.
My favorite part of this doc
is when Navalny's team goes to
the shores of the Black Sea,
they blow up this inflatable boat,
and then they get a drone in the air
and they fly over this giant palace
on the shores of Black Sea.
And then they do what I love,
which is animation on top of drone footage
to help expose a crazy story.
They start to pick apart
every aspect of this palace
to get the original blueprints
to show that there's a
hockey rink in the basement,
there's a full casino, and all of this
for the benefit of the
president of the country.
But of course, it's not
owned by the president,
it's owned by his buddies.
Some rich billionaire
dude actually owns it
but who actually benefits from it?
Putin.
It's like a symbol of
the whole Russian system
in one drone shot, it's
freaking beautiful.
No political leader should
have a palace like this.
- [Reporter] Alexei Navalny
who returned to Moscow for the first time
since he was poisoned last summer.
- Navalny lands in
Moscow, and what happens?
He's immediately arrested.
On what charges?
Well, they claimed that
he was violating parole
from some old fake set of charges
brought against him years ago
that were thrown out later,
they were totally fake,
and yet the Russian state
continued to say that he
had to report for parole.
Turns out he couldn't
report to parole offices
because he was in a coma
from being poisoned by
the Russian government,
and yet he gets arrested.
- [Reporter] He'd only been back
on Russian soil a few minutes
when Alexei Navalny was
told he was being detained,
a kiss goodbye for his wife Yulia.
- Russia's justice system
has been a sham for a long time.
This isn't new, but just
how blatant this is,
how clearly faked all
of this is to silence
a threat to the leader,
that's a new law for Russia
and its justice system.
(slow music plays)
So Navalny is arrested and put on trial,
the people take to the streets
of Moscow and around the country.
The police meet them with force
arresting over a thousand protestors,
and now arresting journalists.
Here's a clip of Navalny's lawyer
speaking openly to the media
in the middle of Moscow,
and out of nowhere,
a group of policemen come detain her.
(people murmuring)
In broad daylight.
While the protestors clashed
with the police outside the courthouse,
Navalny stands in a glasscage
while a largely politically
motivated sham trial
about parole violation takes place.
His wife Yulia is in the
courtroom in the audience
watching this all happen,
they're making eye contact.
And in the end,
the system does what it's supposed to do,
Navalny gets two years and
eight months of prison time.
The house of cards stays stable
for at least a little longer.
(people protesting)
This movement was never about
Alexei Navalny or his politics,
and it likely never will be,
he will never be the leader of Russia.
His role in all of this
is focused on one thing,
showing the people how
their country really works,
ripping away the curtain that veils
how their government uses
the resources of the people
and who it serves and who it doesn't.
Doing so threatens the security
of Vladimir Putin and his friends.
Which is why the system is reacting,
going to greater and greater lengths
to muzzle Navalny and anyone like him.
The question for me is,
how far will this go?
How much is too much
before the Russian people decide
to take back their country?
(slow music playing)
(people protesting)
Thank you for watching this video,
it is unfolding right now,
and by the time you're watching this,
there may be new information about this.
I'm putting a bunch of
links in the description
for some of the videos that I mentioned
that you should go watch
if you want to learn more.
I now want to thank today's sponsor
which is a thing I have used forever,
which is Audible.
Audible is a place that
used to just be audiobooks,
and that's why I got into it
like literally 10 years ago.
Now, it is a place that has audiobooks
but also tons of other audio
spoken word, just content.
What I love about Audible is that you can
sign up for this subscription
and then basically you can
pick out one audiobook,
no matter how much it costs, you get it
for your subscription fee every month,
and you get access to a bunch of other
unlimited content, podcasts, audiobooks,
all sorts of really amazing stuff
all on the app.
I really love Audible
because it gets me learning so much.
I will often listen to an audiobook
while I'm working on a story
so that I can get up to speed
on the background of that story
and become just more informed
about the topics that I'm covering.
The audiobook I'm listening to right now,
well, I'm listening to a bunch actually
but the one I'm really loving
is called "Fluent Forever."
It is the psychology of language learning,
I just did a language
learning class on bright trip
and I'm like deep in the
science of language learning.
It's an amazing listen,
I'm learning a ton.
I also have loads of
Italian language audiobooks
that I'm listening to.
Like I'm listening to "Hunger
Games" in Italian right now,
it's really nice learning to punch.
Anyway, because you are
watching this before Presidents' Day
here in the United States,
you are gonna get in on
one of the biggest sales
of the year that Audible does.
You can get a subscription to Audible
for $9.95 a month for
your first six months.
That is insanely cheap,
you pay less than $10 a month
and you get any audiobook
in the entire collection
for that subscription fee,
plus access to all this
unlimited audio content.
It's a crazy good deal
and it is a no brainer for me.
So go to audible.com/johnnyharris
or text "Johnny Harris"
to the phone number of 500-500
if that's easier for you
and you can get in on this deal.
Clicking that link in my description
helps support this channel
but it also gets you
in on this killer deal
that you don't wanna miss.
So thank you all for being here,
thank you all for watching,
more videos to come,
I'll see you in the next one.
(slow music playing)